[Music]
[Music]
all these points are very critical
phenomena setup Ottoman Empire then back
down critical places where critical
commanders and soldiers have to pee
thanks
the hard time we're going to go ahead
and makes a lot mustard in the town of
doujin as you know this when you come
into a house of worship
who said house of God you have no
statues here you have no Idol worship
it's simply worshiping the creator the
universe the Creator Jesus Moses Abraham
the last and final messenger sent to you
as a mercy to all of humanity if anybody
looks into his life and the evidence
that he came with the Quran you will see
and come to the conclusion as all these
people who are here coming together on
pure monotheism to worship the One God
you can obviously pray outside of the
mosque but there's more reward here so
the community comes together here to
worship together and to do other good
activities humanitarian programs things
for the youth educational programs
things of goodness things that are
pleasing to the creator of the heavens
and earth and Arabic Allah
teach summer
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
we're gonna build okay language there
Nick who's this jerk just like judo or
in jujitsu
if one door closed then we go to another
door and I can go ahead
[Music]
[Music]
anything you can say about this anything
you can recommend helping the
non-muslims to learn about Islam and
helping Muslims also to appreciate what
they have of Islam Sipos attracted
militaries and Islam has the solutions
for all of the world's problems the
other katene problem is a and finish
with the arm okay so I'm looking for his
leg
[Music]
one more I don't I can't hear you the
about of you Alfonzo do you live with
anaconda Jakarta Jakarta who don't max
eject you okay let's go
Thank You Todd thank you all of you guys
very nice fabulous job probably stretch
hope you enjoyed the seminar
you know Habib the fighter he oh he oh
he said he wanted the best Muslim
fighters he never does like this hundred
in that we're here free just finish up
the seminar
everybody got to learn some good jujitsu
and during our time here in Turkey